let me ask you about the the maker
movement seem to predate sort of what
you did and you kind of got into the
maker space
yeah and now they've kind of collided in
a way it seems like you have these
families where yeah maybe the boys are
doing one set of making the mom is doing
another one is there an aunt is this all
about like anti capitalism or is it an
anti digital in like in that I want to
actually get back to something more pure
and instead of just wasting my time
playing video games and consuming TV
shows I just want to as a human being
feel something in my hands and feel the
the joy of creating something in the
real world as opposed to farmville or
leveling up in Minecraft or whatever the
heck they're doing so I think there are
like three different things at play here
one for this generation meaning largely
Millennials and then gen Z which is
which is even more into the maker
movement than Millennials they have
grown up with tech and digital so you're
right yes they want to get away from the
screens a little bit they want to it's
like literally in our instincts in our
you know ancestry to know how to make
things to survive like cavemen had to
build homes and make food to survive and
the fact that a lot of us don't know how
to make eggs when we go off to college
is scary and we want to and it's cool to
do that again and so I do think that
there's a little bit of that at play
we've also grown up in this era of
big-box retailers right when I was a kid
in the 80s and 90s it was you know um
McDonald you know the McDonald's
fast-food you know all the fast-food
chains it was you know all the same
clothing brands them at the mall we all
shopped at the same places and now
because of social media everyone wants
to be different
everyone wants to be unique and they
want to share that with other people so
I actually think the biggest trend at
play here is the notion of customization
and personalization and the fact that
self manufacturing at home whether
you're printing a pair of earrings on a
3d printer I saw you just invested in a
desktop metal which is awesome
I was an angel investor in Santa Clau up
was the guy who created a 1-2-3 systems
- battery pack company and then he told
me I'm gonna make a metal 3d printer and
I was like a 3d printer that prints
metal can I invest in that he said yeah
okay if you want to you might lose your
money I'm like
it's kind of the business I'm in let's
go women wouldn't attritional EB
metalworkers some are right but like if
you say to them well you can make your
own jewelry you can make forks and
spoons that have your like family
initials on them you can you know do all
these things it's like their mind
explodes what more could you want one of
the Meo every producer let my executive
assistant jazz know that I need Rick
Philip to send that desktop 3d metal
$100,000 printer on loan for a year to
Bret and heshes but in exchange he's
gonna just give him a link back I'll hit
some links for you it really is about
the follow back and the link the link
back yeah well but what's interesting
about you're saying about customization
is if you it really is a reaction in
your mind to just this corporate cookie
cutter mass production of stuff and if
you it's interesting if you look at
Coachella in a way it really is this
self expression or Burning Man which is
kind of like the more hardcore version
of Coachella Coachella is kind of like
the little easier version but people
really go there to make their outfit to
- yeah nice their statement its artistic
expression in a way totally Coachella
and it's huge with young women right
like and they're sharing everything on
Instagram and everything on snapchat
they want to be different they want to
be known that they did something in a
new way that's different from their
friends that's special and unique to
them I think for gifting purposes to
like it's just innate I gave my mom
every Mother's Day about her a jewelry
like jewelry a necklace whatever one day
I've made her one instead literally
every time I see her she's wearing that
necklace um there's something about the
fact that you put in time to do this for
me um whether you cooked something for
me I try to tell my husband this a lot
I'm like can you please
and so it's Mother's Day like don't buy
me flowers but make me a meal like put
in some effort you know like the
traditional husband wife and
conversation but but that you know that
goes a long way I think it's really
meaningful human-to-human you know
interaction and connection